Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. No, my lord count, you will not have her. You will not have her. Because you are a great noble man, you think you are a great genius. Nobility, fortune, rank, position. How proud they make a man feel. What have you done to deserve such advantage?
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。不，伯爵大人，你得不到她。你得不到她。因为你是一位伟大的贵族，你以为自己是个天才。高贵的出身、财富、地位、权势。这些让一个人感到多么自豪。你做了什么才配得上这样的优越条件？
Put yourself to the trouble of being born, nothing more. For the rest, a very ordinary man. Whereas I, lost among the obscure crowd, have had to deploy more knowledge, more calculation, and skill merely to survive than has surpassed the rule of the provinces of Spain for a century. Yet you, Tom Holland, would measure yourself against me. So that, Tom, is the most famous speech in the most celebrated and controversial play that was staged in the reign of Louis XVI. And that play is The Marais de Figaro by Pierre Beaumarchais. And that first appeared in April 1784. And today's episode is about the scandal of the diamond necklace. So before we get into the
你不过是费心投胎到了好人家，仅此而已。除此之外，你只是个极其平庸的人。而我，淹没在默默无闻的人群中，为了生存所付出的知识、算计和技巧，比统治西班牙各省一个世纪的人还要多。然而你，汤姆·霍兰德，竟然想和我相提并论。所以，汤姆，这就是路易十六统治时期上演的最著名、最受赞誉也最具争议的戏剧中最著名的演讲。那部戏就是皮埃尔·博马舍的《费加罗的婚礼》。它于1784年4月首次亮相。而今天的节目是关于钻石项链的丑闻。所以在我们进入
diamond necklace and what it means for Marion Trenet, for Louis XVI and for the French Revolution, tell us why you've chosen to kick off with the marriage of Figaro and what is going on? That was excellent reading. Oh, thank you. I loved the kind of the Gallic laughter. Yeah. But Dominic, I mean, just one thing, shouldn't he have had a Spanish accent because Figaro is Spanish? I did think about that. I did think about that. But the French are pretty uncompromising, aren't they, when it comes to this kind of thing. So I think they would not have done a Spanish accent. They would have been unrepentantly gallic about
钻石项链以及它对玛丽·安托瓦内特、路易十六和法国大革命意味着什么之前，告诉我们你为什么选择以《费加罗的婚礼》作为开场，这到底是怎么回事？那段朗读太棒了。哦，谢谢。我喜欢那种高卢式的笑声。是的。但多米尼克，我的意思是，有一点，他不应该有西班牙口音吗？因为费加罗是西班牙人？我确实考虑过这一点。我确实考虑过。但法国人在这种事情上相当不妥协，不是吗？所以我认为他们不会用西班牙口音。他们会毫不悔改地保持高卢风格
it. And that was what I was trying to convey. Yeah, fair enough. Fair enough. So the marriage of Figaro, which if people haven't seen the play, they may have seen the opera, which was adapted by Mozart. And it tells the story of the wedding day of Figaro, who is the servant of a lecherous and arrogant Spanish count called Count Alma Viva. And Figaro has just got married to Suzanne, who is the maid of the countess, the count's wife. And the count, who is, I mean, he makes Louis XV, who we had in the previous episode, look at an absolute model of chastity. He wants to exercise the traditional droit de seigneur over Suzanne.
那是我想传达的。是的，很有道理。很有道理。那么《费加罗的婚礼》，如果人们没看过这部戏，他们可能看过莫扎特改编的歌剧。它讲述了费加罗的婚礼当天的故事，费加罗是一位好色且傲慢的西班牙伯爵——阿尔马维瓦伯爵的仆人。费加罗刚刚娶了苏珊娜，她是伯爵夫人——也就是伯爵妻子的女仆。而这位伯爵，我的意思是，他让我们在上一集提到的路易十五看起来简直是贞洁的典范。他想对苏珊娜行使传统的“初夜权”。
So the right of a lord to bed whoever of his dependents he wants to. And all kinds of farcical shenanigans ensue, Dominic. Love a farcical shenanigan. So lots of cross-dressing, lots of hiding in cupboards, jumping out of windows, all kinds of things like that. But the plot ends up in a garden by night and the Countess and Suzanne have kind of teamed up and they've got this plan to basically publicly humiliate the Count and kind of get him to reform out of shame. And so to that end, they've swapped clothes so that the Count will mistake his wife, the Countess, for the maid, Suzanne, and vice versa. So it's a kind of classic French farce. And Figaro is worried that Suzanne is going to sleep with the Count, even though they've just
也就是领主有权与他属下的任何女性同床。于是发生了一连串荒诞的闹剧，多米尼克。我喜欢荒诞的闹剧。所以有很多易装、躲在橱柜里、跳窗等等各种各样的事情。但情节最终在夜晚的花园里展开，伯爵夫人和苏珊娜联手了，她们有一个计划，基本上是要公开羞辱伯爵，让他因羞愧而改过自新。为此，她们交换了衣服，这样伯爵就会把他的妻子——伯爵夫人误认为是女仆苏珊娜，反之亦然。所以这是一种经典的法国闹剧。费加罗担心苏珊娜会和伯爵睡觉，尽管他们才刚刚
got married, and furious about it. And so that's what's provoked the rant that you began this episode with. He's very upset that the Count is behaving like this, understandably. And so that's what's provoked the rant that you began this episode with. He's very upset that the Count is behaving like this, understandably. And he also thinks that Suzanne is betraying him. And so he's assembled a large crowd to catch the Count and Suzanne in flagrante because he thinks this is what's going to happen. But it all ends very happily. Hurrah! Because Suzanne is very indignant that Figaro wouldn't trust him, reveals the whole plot to him. The couple are reconciled. They have a kiss.
结婚，对此感到愤怒。这就是引发你本集开头那段咆哮的原因。他非常难过，伯爵竟然做出这种事，这可以理解。这就是引发你本集开头那段咆哮的原因。他非常难过，伯爵竟然做出这种事，这可以理解。而且他还认为苏珊娜背叛了他。于是他召集了一大群人去捉奸，因为他认为这一定会发生。但结局非常圆满。万岁！因为苏珊娜对费加罗不信任她感到非常愤慨，向他揭露了整个计划。这对夫妇和解了。他们亲吻了。
The Count sees them kissing and thinks that Figaro is getting off with his wife, the Countess. Absolutely explodes, orders them all to be arrested. The crowd summoned by Figaro kind of assemble on the stage, you know, with flaming torches and everything. At this point, the Countess emerges and reveals who she is. The Count realises that he's been an. The count realizes that he's been an absolute bounder, that he's been tricked, and there's a long pause, and then he falls to his knees and begs for forgiveness. In the opera, I mean, it's a stunningly beautiful moment.
伯爵看到他们亲吻，以为费加罗在和他的妻子——伯爵夫人调情。彻底爆发了，命令把他们全都抓起来。费加罗召集的人群聚集在舞台上，你知道，拿着火把什么的。这时，伯爵夫人现身并揭露了自己的身份。伯爵意识到他一直是个混蛋。伯爵意识到他一直是个彻头彻尾的无赖，他被耍了，现场陷入了长时间的沉默，然后他跪倒在地，请求宽恕。在歌剧中，我的意思是，那是一个极其美丽的时刻。
And the countess does forgive him, and everyone is forgiven. And the last line of the plays, which is accompanied by music, is, everything finishes with songs. So there's this idea that the class tensions and the iniquities of the aristocracy can be resolved with beautiful music. But at the time, this play by Beaumarchais, 1784, incredibly controversial in France, because it was seen as so radical in that it was upturning the social order. There are lots of jokes and remarks and allusions to censorship or the way the social order. There are lots of jokes and remarks and allusions to censorship or the way the justice system works or the fear of being locked up in the Bastille. Now, in Robert Darnton's brilliant book, The Revolutionary Temper, there's a whole
伯爵夫人确实原谅了他，每个人都得到了宽恕。戏剧的最后一句台词，伴随着音乐，是“一切都以歌声结束”。所以有一种观点认为，阶级矛盾和贵族的罪恶可以通过美妙的音乐来解决。但在当时，博马舍的这部戏（1784年）在法国引起了极大的争议，因为它被视为如此激进，因为它颠覆了社会秩序。戏里有很多关于审查制度、社会秩序运作方式或对被关进巴士底狱的恐惧的笑话、评论和影射。现在，在罗伯特·达恩顿的杰作《革命的脾气》中，有一整章
chapter about the controversy about the marriage of Figaro and how that foreshadows the revolution. Yeah. And I mean, people listening to that praise me, they were able to keep track of it. They may be wondering, how could a farce like this have this kind of incredible reputation? I mean, it had it at the time, and it had it in the revolution. So Danton, who we'll be coming to, one of the great revolutionary leaders, he says of it, it killed off the nobility. I mean, you might think actually it's the guillotine that does that, but Danton says, no, it's the marriage of Figaro and napoleon says of the play because we remember we did the episodes on the young napoleon didn't we he loved to play yeah and he said that you know
专门讲述关于《费加罗的婚礼》的争议以及它如何预示了革命。是的。我的意思是，听众们听到这里，如果他们能跟上节奏，他们可能会想，一部这样的闹剧怎么会有如此不可思议的声誉？我的意思是，它在当时就有，在革命时期也有。所以丹东，我们稍后会讲到他，作为伟大的革命领袖之一，他评价说：“它杀死了贵族。”我的意思是，你可能认为实际上是断头台做了这件事，但丹东说，不，是《费加罗的婚礼》。而拿破仑谈到这部戏时——因为我们记得我们做过关于年轻拿破仑的剧集，不是吗？他很喜欢这部戏——他说，你知道
this is the revolution in action avant la revolution this is what the revolution is going to become right so the obvious question then if it is as incendiary as contemporaries thought how on earth did it come to be staged and and not only come to be staged, but become, I mean, unbelievably famous, kind of in the way that a blockbusting Hollywood movie today might be. Going completely viral, copied, parodied. So, you know, the fact that Mozart turns it into an opera within two years of it being premiered is a kind of indication of the cultural cachet that it has and the celebrity and indeed the notoriety. And the truth is that the difficulty of getting it on stage becomes part of Beaumarchais' marketing strategy. So he gives the finished script to the Comédie-Française in 1781. And they say, yeah, this is brilliant. It's a sequel to a
这就是革命在行动，在革命之前，这就是革命将要变成的样子，对吧？所以显而易见的问题是，如果它像同时代人认为的那样具有煽动性，它到底是怎么被搬上舞台的？而且不仅被搬上舞台，还变得——我的意思是，难以置信地出名，就像今天的好莱坞大片一样。完全病毒式传播，被复制、被模仿。所以，你知道，莫扎特在它首演两年内就把它改编成歌剧，这表明了它所具有的文化地位、名气，甚至是臭名昭著。事实是，让它登上舞台的困难成了博马舍营销策略的一部分。他在1781年把完成的剧本交给了法兰西喜剧院。他们说，是的，这太棒了。这是
previous play that had also featured Figaro in the Count. So they're very keen to put it on, but it takes them three years to get on. And the reason for that is that the king is massively offended by it. He calls it detestable. He particularly hates the speech that you just read, and he repeatedly tries to ban it. But he reckons without two things. And one of them is Beaumarchais himself, who is an amazing figure, incredibly charismatic, extraordinary life. He'd been a royal agent in London. He'd been sent there to protect Madame du Barry, Louis XV's mistress from a libelous pamphlet. He'd had all kinds of dealings with the Chevalier d'Eon, who is a diplomat who people think may even have been female, but it's kind of a cross-dresser. And again, kind of cross-dressing is a kind of theme throughout
之前一部同样以费加罗和伯爵为主角的戏的续集。所以他们非常热衷于上演它，但他们花了三年时间才成功。原因在于国王对此感到极度冒犯。他称之为“可憎的”。他特别讨厌你刚才读的那段演讲，并反复试图禁止它。但他低估了两件事。其中之一是博马舍本人，他是一个了不起的人物，极具魅力，生活非凡。他曾是伦敦的皇家特工。他被派往那里保护路易十五的情妇杜巴利夫人免受诽谤小册子的伤害。他与德昂骑士有过各种往来，德昂骑士是一位外交官，人们认为他甚至可能是女性，但他是某种易装者。同样，易装也是贯穿
the Marriage of Figaro. He ends up running guns to the Americans. He publishes the complete works of Voltaire, The Great Wit and Philosoph. So an amazing guy and is brilliant at self-publicity. And he uses the censorship battle to publicise the play. And he's able to do this by exploiting what we were talking about in the previous episode, that there are different factions in the court. And lots of the nobility who are opposed to the stuffiness of the king think it's very very funny to get the play on yeah and one of the people who thinks it's funny to get the play on is the queen herself marie antoinette who we talked about the last time who's been behaving in a way that they think is not suitable for a queen because
《费加罗的婚礼》的一个主题。他最终为美国人走私军火。他出版了伏尔泰——这位伟大的智者和哲学家的全集。所以他是一个了不起的人，非常擅长自我宣传。他利用审查之争来宣传这部戏。他之所以能做到这一点，是因为利用了我们在上一集谈到的，宫廷里存在不同的派系。许多反对国王古板作风的贵族认为上演这部戏非常非常有趣。是的，其中一个认为上演这部戏很有趣的人就是王后本人——玛丽·安托瓦内特，我们上次谈到过她，她的行为方式被认为不适合王后，因为
of her love of the kind of rusousseauist nature and simplicity and stuff. And because she's kind of got a girlishness to her, a lightness. And French queens are meant to be heavy. Yeah. And she thinks it's hilarious, doesn't she? She thinks it's really funny. She does. So Simon Sharma in Citizen says, the more outrageous the denunciations of the established
她对卢梭式的自然和朴素的热爱等等。而且因为她有一种少女气，一种轻盈感。而法国王后本应是庄重的。是的。她觉得这太搞笑了，不是吗？她觉得这真的很有趣。确实如此。所以西蒙·沙玛在《公民》中说，对既定秩序的谴责越离谱，王后就越喜欢。这是因为她在宫廷里合不来的人是那种死板、正式、老派的人。而这些人某种程度上不喜欢这部戏，并被它嘲弄，对吧？所以她自然站在轻盈和欢笑这一边，汤姆。绝对是。而且国王的兄弟之一，不是那个特别愤世嫉俗的普罗旺斯伯爵，而是更年轻的兄弟——阿图瓦伯爵，他和玛丽·安托瓦内特关系非常亲密，我的意思是，他也喜欢这部戏。他推动它上演。于是它成为了一个巨大的、巨大的“名声的成功”，不仅是在普通的剧院观众中，而且在
order, the better the queen liked it. And that's because the people that she doesn't get on with at the court are the kind of rigid, formal, old guard kind of people. And they're the kind of people to some degree who don't like this play and are being mocked by it, right? So she's naturally on the side of lightness and laughter, Tom. Absolutely. And one of the king's brothers, so not the Comte de Provence, who is the kind of particularly embittered one, but the younger brother, the Comte d'Artois, who's very close to Marie Antoinette, I mean, he loves it as well. He pushes for it to be on. And so it becomes a massive, massive succès d'estime, not just among the ordinary mass of theatre goers, but among the
贵族中也是如此。同样，沙玛在叙述中引用了一位贵族亨丽埃特·德·弗罗因斯坦的话，她描述观众席上的所有贵族都在自打耳光，嘲笑他们自己的开销，更糟糕的是，还让别人也笑，这是一种奇怪的盲目。但说到奇怪的盲目，那是1784年春天，有闹剧、幽会、伪装，所有这些事情。然后，难以置信的是，仅仅几周后，一场丑闻就开始了，它让《费加罗的婚礼》的故事、那些荒诞的闹剧相比之下显得平淡、无趣且苍白。这就是这场巨大丑闻的开始——钻石项链事件，
nobility. And again, Sharma, in his account of this, quotes an aristocrat, Henriette de Freundstein, who describes all the aristocrats in the audience slapping themselves on their own cheeks, laughing at their own expense, and even worse, making others laugh too, a strange blindness. But talking of a strange blindness, so that's in the spring of 1784, that there's this farce, assignations, disguises, all of this kind of thing. And then, unbelievably, just weeks later, there will begin an affair, scandal, that makes the story of the marriage of Figaro, the farcical goings-on, look humdrum and unfunny and colourless by comparison. And this is the beginning of this tremendous scandal, the affair of the diamond necklace,
汤姆。我没说错的话，这是在1784年8月11日开始的。所以仅仅几个月后。是的。所以《费加罗的婚礼》在1784年春天首演。正如你所说，8月11日发生了一件事，奇怪地呼应了《费加罗的婚礼》中的高潮场景。但正如你所说，它升级到了丑闻的程度。那天晚上，一位名叫妮可·勒盖的巴黎女帽商，因高利贷者的压榨而沦为妓女（或者她是这么说的），被带到了凡尔赛。引用乔纳森·贝克曼的话——他不仅是一位历史学家，还在作者队里和我一起打板球，但他写了一部关于整个丑闻的精彩著作《如何毁掉一位王后》。他对妮可的描述是：她年轻、漂亮、身无分文。有着宽阔的前额、笔直的雕塑般的鼻子和微凸的小嘴，多米尼克，她长得简直就像玛丽·安托瓦内特。所以她被带到凡尔赛，在那里受到了一位自称瓦卢瓦子爵夫人的女人的迎接，她告诉妮可一件惊人的事：王后亲自请求妮可帮王后一个忙，作为回报，妮可将获得15000里弗尔，这对一个贫困的妓女来说是一大笔钱。
Tom. And this kicks off, am I right in saying, on the 11th of August, 1784. So just a few months later. Yeah. So the Marriage of Figaro has premiered in the spring of 1784. And as you say, on the 11th of August, an event happens that weirdly echoes the kind of the climactic scene in the Marriage of Figaro. But as you said, ramps it up to a scandalous degree. So that evening, a Parisian milliner called Nicole Le Gay, who has been reduced to prostitution by the exactions of loan sharks, or so she says, is driven to Versailles. And to quote Jonathan Beckman, who is not only a historian, but plays cricket with me in the authors, but has written a brilliant
巨额资金。是的。不仅如此，因为她在帮王后的忙，她将被授予一个头衔。瓦卢瓦子爵夫人说，从现在起，妮可将被尊称为奥利瓦男爵夫人。那是O-L-I-V-A，这是一种瓦卢瓦的变位词，几乎是瓦卢瓦的变位词。这概率有多大？不得不说，当时妮可的怀疑并没有被激起。事实上，
account of the whole scandal, How to Ruin a Queen. His description of Nicole, she was young, pretty and broke. And with her broad forehead, her straight chiseled nose and her small protuberant mouth, she resembled Dominic, no one so much as Marie Antoinette. So she gets driven to Versailles and she's greeted there by a woman who calls herself the Vicomtesse de Valois, who tells Nicole something amazing, that the queen has personally requested that her Nicole do the queen a favor and that in return, Nicole will be given 15,000 livres, which is a lot of money for an impecunious prostitute.
她只是感到非常困惑。但获得头衔和一大笔钱的机会，我的意思是。是的。为什么不接受呢？是的。有什么不好的？所以她留在了凡尔赛。第二天，她穿上了一种朴素但昂贵的白色细棉布裙。听过我们之前剧集的人会知道，这是玛丽·安托瓦内特本人的标志性装束。她戴着一顶半遮面帽，遮住了她的脸，但让人能看到她的嘴唇。子爵夫人随后递给——让我们叫她奥利瓦夫人，因为那是她现在的头衔——一封小信，并说她将带她进入凡尔赛公园，进入其中一个花园。当她到达那里时，一位高贵的领主会在那里等候。她要交出这封信和一朵玫瑰。当她
Huge amounts of money. Yeah. And more than that, because she's doing the queen a favor, she will be given a title. And the Vicomtesse de Valois says that from this point on, Nicole will be known as the Baron d'Oliva. And that is O-L-I-V-A, which is kind of an anagram of Valois, almost an anagram of Valois. What are the chances? So Nicole's suspicions are not aroused by this, it has to be said at the time. In fact,
递出信和玫瑰时，她要对这位领主说：“你知道这意味着什么。”这就是她要做的全部事情。于是午夜时分，奥利瓦男爵夫人（她似乎已经变成了这样）被带到了花园里。在被带过去的时候，她被告知王后正在看着她，以确保她做了王后要求的一切。所以奥利瓦男爵夫人——妮可，也就是妮可，那个贫困的女帽商，是的，站在花园里，你知道周围有玫瑰，远处有喷泉微弱的溅水声，星星在天空中闪烁。没过多久，她看到一个男人向她走来，这是一个穿着黑色长袍、戴着宽边软帽的男人。他走到她面前，可怜的男爵夫人吓坏了。她不知道这个人是谁。她在皇家花园里。发生了什么事？她
she's just incredibly bewildered. But the chance to have a title and lots of money, I mean. Yeah. Why wouldn't you take it? Yeah. What's not to like? So she stayed at Versailles. The next day she's dressed in kind of a plain but expensive white muslin dress. And people who heard our previous episodes will know that this is the kind of signature costume of Marie Antoinette herself. And she's given a demi bonnet, which covers her face, but kind of enables people to see her lips. The vicomtesse then hands, let's call her Doliva, because that's now her title, a tiny letter and says that she is going to lead her into the park at Versailles, into one of the gardens. And that when she gets there, a noble seigneur will be waiting. And she's to hand this letter over plus a rose. And as she
鼓起勇气，递过玫瑰，并按照指示说：“你知道这意味着什么。”她正要递出那封信，突然传来一阵喧闹声，远处有火把，有脚步声传来，男爵夫人的手臂被抓住，拉进了灌木丛。是子爵夫人抓住了她，匆忙把她带回去，带进了她的私人住所。奥利瓦男爵夫人——妮可，道歉说她没能递出那封信。但似乎没人关心。相反，有一顿大餐，美酒流淌，然后他们去睡觉了。第二天早上，子爵夫人向妮可——奥利瓦男爵夫人展示了她收到的一封来自玛丽·安托瓦内特的信。她读了这封信。我非常高兴，我亲爱的子爵夫人，
hands the letter and the rose over, she is to say to this seigneur, you know what this means. And that's all she has to do. And so at midnight, the Baron d'Oliva, as she seems to have become, is taken out into the gardens. And she is told as she's being led that the queen is watching her to make sure that she does everything that the queen has requested so the baron d'oliva nicole aka nicole the impecunious milliner yeah is standing in the gardens you know the kind of roses around faint splashing of fountains in the distance the stars are blazing in the sky not long afterwards she sees a man approaching her and this is a man in a long black cassock and a very broad-brimmed floppy hat. He comes up to her and the poor Baron is terrified. She doesn't know who this person is. She's in the royal gardens. What's going on? She
对你为我找来的人。她完美地扮演了她的角色。此时，子爵夫人撕碎了这封信，因为她说这不是那种应该随身携带的信。所以没有任何证据证明这一切发生过。子爵夫人随后交出了承诺费用的三分之一。然后奥利瓦男爵夫人被送回了巴黎。从这一点开始，再也没有提到她的头衔。所以她又变回了妮可，也没有更多的钱了。事情似乎就这样结束了。我的意思是，一切都非常非常奇怪。这是妮可自己的说法，不是吗？嗯，这是她律师的说法。是的。你在这段故事中听到的所有内容都来自不同律师提供的说法，为了赚钱，出版了他们客户告诉他们的回忆录。但多米尼克，公平地说，也是为了试图让他们的客户脱罪，正如我们将要看到的。是的，当然。所以这是妮可的故事。所以，汤姆，这一集非常适合莫扎特。非常非常莫扎特。王后在注视着，大概是黑暗中一个神秘的追求者，递出的玫瑰，所有这些事情。
summons up her courage and she hands over the rose and she says, as she's been instructed to do, you know what this means. She's just about to hand over the letter when there's suddenly a kind of an uproar, torches in the distance, the sound of footsteps coming and the Baron's arm is grabbed, pulled into the bushes. It's the V Comtesse who's got hold of her, hurries her back, takes her into her private quarters. And the Baron d'Oliveur, Nicole, apologises that she hasn't been able to hand over the letter. But nobody seems to care. Instead, there's a big meal, the wine flows, and they go to bed. And in the morning, the V-Comtesse shows Nicole, the Baron d'Oliveau, a letter that she has received from Marie Antoinette. And she reads the letter out. I'm very happy, my dear Countess,
我的意思是，这是为歌剧而生的。是的。为我们打开灯，首先告诉我们，那个穿着长袍的神秘男人是谁，王后似乎在给他一朵玫瑰？嗯，他在法国贵族等级制度中是一个极其重要的人物。他叫路易·德·罗昂，是法国最显赫的非皇室家族的后裔。所以他将自己的血统追溯到曾经的布列塔尼国王。罗昂家族有这样一句话：“我不能成为国王，我不想成为王子，我是罗昂。”
with the person you procured for me. She played her role to perfection. At this point, the V-Comtesse rips up the letter because she says it is not the kind of letter that one should carry around. So there is no evidence for any of this that's happened. The V-Com Tess then hands over a third of the fee that's been promised. And then the Baron d'Oliver is driven back into Paris. From this point on, there is no further reference to her title. So she goes back to being Nicole and there is no further money. And that seems to be the end of the matter. I mean, all very, very strange. And this is from Nicole's own account, isn't it? Well, it's from the account of her lawyer. Yeah. Everything you're going to hear in this
所以成为罗昂比成为国王或王子更好。希优顿会同意这一点，汤姆。当然，当然。作为罗昂，他继承了斯特拉斯堡的主教职位，这带来了红衣主教的身份。他继承了这个职位，成为了罗昂红衣主教。对。
story comes from the accounts given by different lawyers to make money, publish memoirs of what their clients had told them. But also, Dominic, to be fair, to try and get their clients off, as we will see. Yes, of course. So this is Nicole's story. So, Tom, a very kind of Mozart-friendly episode, this. It's very, very Mozart. The Queen looking on, presumably a mysterious suitor in the darkness, the roses handed over, all or this kind of thing.
在他的性格中，他是一个非常慷慨的人，但在其他方面，我的意思是，他是一个很容易被骗子欺骗的人。我认为这样说是公平的。他基本上是本·琼森戏剧或莫里哀戏剧中的一个角色。他就是那种如果收到一封邮件说“我需要你的护照信息和10万英镑，请汇到这里”，他就会照做的人。所以有一个修道院院长，年轻时曾和他一起在神学院，记得他傲慢、轻率、不讲理、挥霍无度、不太聪明、在品味和友谊上反复无常。但正如我所说，他确实有两个优点。他非常慷慨，而且多米尼克，他是一个亲英派。所以这些是积极的。试图打击。一个字也不会听反对他的话。问题是，他激怒了玛丽·安托瓦内特。玛丽·安托瓦内特讨厌他。原因是他曾作为大使去过维也纳。因为他是亲英派，他并不真正喜欢奥地利人。他总是写一些关于玛丽·安托瓦内特的母亲——玛丽亚·特蕾莎的粗鲁信件，寄给他在凡尔赛的知己。其中一个人读出了他关于玛丽亚·特蕾莎的粗鲁言论，这传到了玛丽·安托瓦内特耳中。所以她对此非常难过。当他从
I mean, it's made for an opera. Yeah. Turn on the lights for us and tell us, first of all, who is that mysterious man in the cassock that the queen appears to be giving a rose to? Well, he is an amazingly important figure in the French noble hierarchy. He's a man called Louis de Rohan, and he is a scion of the grandest non-royal family in France. So he traces his lineage back to the one-time kings of Brittany. The Rohan have this phrase, I cannot be king, I won't be a prince, I am Rohan.
维也纳回来时，他在凡尔赛。他喜欢八卦。他不太聪明。他到处指责玛丽·安托瓦内特与路易十六的弟弟——阿图瓦伯爵有染。这对他来说太鲁莽了。是的。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。而且他还说王后：“她表现出一种轻浮，为一位老练的情人成功追求她铺平了道路。”我的意思是，疯了。是的。他很愚蠢，显然让自己的舌头失控了。看过《危险关系》或读过勒克洛斯在同一时期写的书的人，我的意思是，这正是正在发生的事情。人们互相八卦，偷听，阅读不该读的信件，
So it's better to be Rohan than to be a king or a prince. Theoden would agree with that, Tom. Of course, of course. And in his role as a Rohan, he gets to inherit the Bishopric of Strasbourg, which brings with it a cardinalate. He inherits this and he becomes the Cardinal de Rohan. Right.
所有这些事情。所以这绝对是气候的一部分。但罗昂红衣主教不够聪明，无法从中获利。所以他感到心烦意乱，觉得玛丽·安托瓦内特阻碍了他获得作为罗昂家族成员本应享有的晋升。所以他会做任何事来试图挽回她。就在这时，一个身无分文、有悲惨故事的女人接近了他。是的。这是一个名叫让娜·德·拉莫特的女人。她声称自己是瓦卢瓦家族的后裔，瓦卢瓦家族是传统的皇室家族，在16世纪灭绝，被波旁家族取代。但这显然只是为了吸引红衣主教的胡说八道，不是吗？
And in his character, he's a very generous man, but in other ways, I mean, he's the kind of person who would very easily be taken in by a confidence trickster. I think it's fair to say. He's basically a character from a sort of Ben Johnson play or something, or a Moliere play. He's the kind of person who, if he got an email from someone saying, you know, I need your passport details and £100,000, please send it here, he would do it. So there was an Abbe who'd been at the seminary with him when they were young, who remembered him as haughty, inconsiderate, unreasonable, spendthrift, not very bright, fickle in his tastes and his friendships. But as I say, he does have two good
我的意思是，她是个骗子。嗯，这是故事。这是她的故事。是的。她向红衣主教寻求一些慈善，红衣主教给了她。而且几乎可以肯定他们有染。那是怎么回事？“请给我一些慈善。”“哦，亲爱的。我楼上有慈善。进来吧。”我想这正是它的运作方式。所以红衣主教是一个臭名昭著的女人，
qualities. He's very generous and Dominic, he's an Anglophile. So these are positives. Trying to smite. Won't hear a word against him. The problem is though, that he has infuriated Marie Antoinette. Marie Antoinette hates him. And the reason for that is he'd gone to Vienna as ambassador. And because he's an Anglophile, he doesn't really like the Austrians. And he's always writing rude letters about Maria Theresa, Marie Antoinette's mother, to his confidants at Versailles. And one of them reads out something rude he said about Maria Theresa, and it gets back to Marie Antoinette. So she's very upset about this. And when he comes back from
正如旧制度下的红衣主教往往是的那样。他们肯定必须是，毫无疑问。所以做了这些之后，拉莫特心想，你知道吗？我要瞄准更高。令人惊讶的是，她想在凡尔赛获得住所。于是她劝说红衣主教把她介绍给路易十六的一位姐妹。拉莫特为这一刻做了非常非常巧妙的准备。所以她被介绍给路易十六的姐妹，然后她晕倒了。她被某种东西压倒了。这到底是演的还是真的，我的意思是，谁知道呢？但结果是，她被视为一个遭受了可怕事情的不幸者，因此需要被帮助。这迎合了那种感伤和敏感的精神，这种精神
Vienna, he's in Versailles. He loves a bit of gossip. He's not very bright. He goes around accusing Marie Antoinette of having an affair with the Comte d'Artois, the younger brother of Louis XVI. It's very reckless of him. Yeah. I mean, it's mad. And also he says of the queen, she displays a coquettishness that prepares the way for an accomplished lover to succeed with her. I mean, mad. Yeah. He's foolish and he lets his tongue run away with him, clearly. And people who've seen Dangerous Liaisons or read the book, the book by Leclos, written at exactly this period. I mean, this is exactly what's going on. It's people kind of gossiping about each other, overhearing it, reading letters that aren't meant for them,
绝对是当前的，并与玛丽·安托瓦内特和她在凡尔赛的氛围有关。所以她得到了这些住所，利用这一点，她开始告诉红衣主教，她已经和王后本人成为了好朋友。我的意思是，王后确实有她，你在上一集提到过作为她的“小队”。所以这并非不可能。我的意思是，这可能会发生。对。所以红衣主教完全相信了。然后拉莫特开始说，你知道，进入玛丽·安托瓦内特内心的唯一方法就是给她买法国最臭名昭著的项链。它是由宫廷珠宝商伯默和巴桑格制作的，路易十五曾委托他们制作。它被称为一种“奴隶项链”，因为它看起来像奴隶可能戴的项圈。它由647颗钻石组成，重2800克拉。
all this kind of thing. So it's absolutely part of the climate. But the Cardinal de Rohan is not smart enough really to profit from it. And so he's distraught that he feels that Marie Antoinette is standing in the way of him getting the kind of promotion that he feels should be his right as a Rohan. So he'll do anything to try and get her back. And it's at this point that an impecunious woman with a sob story approaches him. Yeah. And this is a woman called Jeanne de Lamotte. And she claims descent from the Valois, who are the traditional royal family who kind of gone extinct in the 16th century, being replaced by the Bourbons. But that's obviously just rubbish to appeal to the cardinal, isn't it?
所以，我的意思是，它非常庸俗。乔纳森·贝克曼将其描述为“怪诞且几乎字面上无法忍受”。它更像是一件锁子甲，或者是僧侣在忏悔时可能穿的东西，而不是一件令人垂涎的珠宝。这是一条唐纳德·特朗普会为夜店女郎买的项链。是的。也许是为色情明星。不幸的是，珠宝商从未能把它交给杜巴利夫人，因为路易十五去世了。因此，杜巴利夫人被赶出了凡尔赛，没有能力购买它。所以他们被这笔巨额账单困住了，他们需要把它卖给某人。所以
I mean, she's a swindler. Well, this is the story. This is her story. Yeah. And she approaches the cardinal for some charity, which the cardinal gives her. And almost certainly they have an affair. How does that work? I'd like some charity, please. Oh, my dear. I've got some charity upstairs. Come through. I think that's exactly how it works. So the cardinal is a notorious womaniser,
显而易见的人选是玛丽·安托瓦内特。所以他们一直说：“陛下，您想买这个吗？”这根本不是玛丽·安托瓦内特的风格。我的意思是，它有点庸俗。我认为她喜欢自然和朴素，比如，你知道，垂下的卷发，不穿紧身胸衣等等。是的。最重要的是，当然它是为杜巴利夫人制作的。是的。它不仅庸俗。它与那种交际花有联系。所以绝对不是她。而且她也受到了她的母亲和她的丈夫——国王的警告，你知道，停止炫耀珠宝，这不太好。而且我们谈到的理发师莱昂纳德先生，他一直在从她的发型中剔除珠宝，追求自然外观，花朵。所以基本上这根本不是她的东西。她
as cardinals in the Ancien Regime tend to be. They've got to be by law, surely. So having done that, Lamotte then thinks, do you know what? I'm going to aim higher. And amazingly, she wants to get quarters in Versailles. And so she persuades the Cardinal to introduce her to one of the sisters of Louis XVI. And Lamotte has prepared for this moment very, very skillfully. So she's introduced to the sister of Louis XVI and she faints. She's kind of overcome. And whether this is staged or whether it's real, I mean, who knows? But the consequence of this is that she is seen as an unfortunate who has suffered terrible things and therefore needs to be helped. And this plays into the spirit of kind of sentimentality and sensibility that is
不想要它。所以你可能会想，好吧，你知道，红衣主教难道不能做一些粗略的研究吗？他会意识到这是一件疯狂的事情。玛丽·安托瓦内特绝不会想要这条项链。但就在这时，多米尼克，另一个人走进了故事。这就是你非常喜欢的人，不是吗？是的。这是一个意大利神秘主义者，据说是卡里奥斯特罗伯爵。对。
absolutely kind of current and associated with Marie Antoinette and her vibe at Versailles. And so she gets these quarters and using this, she starts telling the Cardinal that she's become great friends with the Queen herself. I mean, the Queen does have her, you referred in the last episode as her squad. So it's not that impossible. I mean, it could happen. Right. So the Cardinal completely believes it. And Lamotte then starts saying, you know, the only way to get to Marie Antoinette's heart is to buy her the most notorious necklace in France. It had been made by the court jewelers, Burma and Basange, who had been commissioned by Louis XV to make this. It's called a kind of slave necklace because it looks like a kind of collar that a slave might wear. And it consists of 647 diamonds and these weigh 2,800 carats.
所以他的故事足以占据多个播客，但只是绝对浓缩一下。他讲了多个不同的故事。其中一些，他说他是马耳他骑士团大师的儿子，或者是来自埃及或奥斯曼帕夏的大人物。有故事说他300岁了。不，甚至更长。是的。有故事说他和耶稣及同伴一起参加了圣经中迦南的婚礼。基本上，事实似乎是，实际上，他要么出生在巴勒莫贫民窟的一个犹太家庭，要么是那不勒斯马车夫的儿子。我们不知道是哪一个。他似乎当过理发师学徒，这是一个有趣的细节。
So, I mean, it's massively vulgar. And so Jonathan Beckman describes it as grotesque and almost literally unbearable. It more resembled an item of chain mail or something a monk might wear in penitential self-chastisement than a coveted piece of jewellery. It's a necklace that Donald Trump would buy for a lady of the night. Yes. For a porn star, perhaps. And unfortunately, the jewellers had never been able to give this to Madame du Barry because Louis XV had died. And so therefore, Madame du Barry had been chucked out of Versailles and wasn't in a position to buy it. And so they're stuck with this enormous bill and they need to sell it to someone. And so the
是的，这里有很多理发师表现得很糟糕。然后他基本上变成了一个骗子，一个职业江湖骗子。他到处走。他说他构思了一种特殊的埃及共济会形式。他有一个假伯爵夫人妻子，她基本上把这个套餐卖给了贵族女士。他似乎在1781年在斯特拉斯堡接触到了红衣主教。而红衣主教，正如你所说，汤姆，是一个绝对的傻瓜。受骗者。对。
obvious person is Marie Antoinette. So they keep saying, Your Majesty, would you like to buy this? And it's not Marie Antoinette's style at all. I mean, it's kind of vulgar. And I think it's nature and simplicity and like, you know, falling curls and no corsets and all that stuff. Yeah. And on top of that, of course it had been made for Madame du Barry. Yeah. It's not just vulgar. It has associations with kind of courtesans. So absolutely not her. And also she has been warned by both her mother and her husband, the King, you know, to stop displaying the bling, that it's not going down well. And also Monsieur Léonard, who we talked about, the hairdresser, he has been phasing jewels out from her hairstyle, going for the natural look, the flowers. So basically it's not her thing at all. She does
我的意思是，这就是成为莫里哀戏剧角色的全部意义。他相信所有关于共济会和神秘学的东西。他相信卡里奥斯特罗是一位炼金术士。有故事，不是吗？我想它们可能不是真的，但有故事说卡里奥斯特罗参与了阴谋，并举行了降神会和神秘仪式来劝说罗昂，关于项链的事情是真的，这是进入玛丽·安托瓦内特内心的途径。当然，骗局总是这样，人们必须
not want it. So you might think, well, you know, couldn't the cardinal have done some cursory research on this? And he'd have realised this is a mad thing. Marie Antoinette would never have wanted this necklace. But it's at this point, Dominic, that another figure steps into the story. And this is someone you're very keen on, isn't it? Yeah. It's an Italian occultist called, supposedly, the Comte di Cagliostro. Yeah.
拼命想要相信他们被告知的情况是真实的。是的，当然。为了清楚起见，什么是骗局，因为它非常复杂。因此故事也非常复杂。本质上，拉莫特想得到这条巨大的钻石项链。她想把它送到她手中，为了做到这一点，她把红衣主教卷入了一个极其复杂的骗局，卡里奥斯特罗是否参与其中，我的意思是，这一点是不可能确定的。但拉莫特让罗昂红衣主教相信玛丽·安托瓦内特想要它的诡计。我的意思是，这就是花园里整个骗局的意义所在。所以是拉莫特。她是那个让妮可出来的人，告诉她去
So his story is enough to take up multiple podcasts, but just to absolutely condense it. He told multiple different stories. Some of them, he said he was the son of the master of the Knights of Malta or a bigwig from Egypt or an Ottoman pasha. There were stories that he was 300 years old. No, even longer. Yeah. Stories that he'd been at the wedding in Cana in the Bible with Jesus and co. Basically what seems to be the truth is that in reality, either he was born in Sicily in the slums of Palermo into a Jewish family, or he's the son of a coachman from Naples. We don't know which. He seems to have had time as an apprentice hairdresser, which is a fun detail.
花园里去见玛丽·安托瓦内特。当然，她并没有见到玛丽·安托瓦内特。整件事都是一个骗局。选择妮可的原因是因为她长得像玛丽·安托瓦内特。因此，会说服罗昂红衣主教这一切都是合法的。而且一切都进行得非常顺利。妮可扮演了她的角色。拉莫特把她扔回了巴黎。这就是为什么没有再与她联系。而且它非常有效，因为现在红衣主教确信玛丽·安托瓦内特真的想要这条钻石项链。
Yeah, a lot of hairdressers behaving badly in this. And then he basically becomes a swindler, a professional charlatan. He goes around. He says he's dreamed up a special Egyptian form of Freemasonry. He's got a fake countess wife, and she sells the package, basically, to aristocratic ladies. And he seems to have come into contact with the cardinal in Strasbourg in 1781. And the cardinal, as you said, Tom, is an absolute flipping dupe. Gull. Yeah.
当然，不仅红衣主教被骗了，珠宝商也被骗了。珠宝商也想相信王后想要这条项链，因为否则，你知道，他们就破产了，除非他们能把它卖掉。是的。所以1784年11月，所以这是，你知道，在凡尔赛花园会面几个月后，红衣主教收到了一封信，上面签着“法国的玛丽·安托瓦内特”，这是一个她绝不会使用的签名，因为那根本不符合外交礼仪。作为一名前外交官，红衣主教应该知道这一点，但他不知道。在这封信中，他被告知红衣主教要为王后购买项链，
I mean, that's the whole thing about being a character from Moliere play. And he believes all this stuff about Freemasonry on the occult. He believes that Cagliostro is an alchemist. And there are stories, aren't there? And I think they're probably not true, but there are stories that Cagliostro is in on the plot and held seances and occult rituals to persuade Roanne that the stuff about the necklace is true and that this is the way to Marie Antoinette's heart. And of course, the thing is always with confidence tricks is that people have to
王后将分四期付款。太棒了。珠宝商很高兴。红衣主教很高兴。你知道，这是他回归的方式。所以1785年1月29日，珠宝商把项链给了红衣主教。然后一个快递员到达，声称来自王后。红衣主教把项链给了这个快递员。那个红衣主教真是个傻瓜，汤姆。我的意思是，难以置信。你认为那是快递员吗，多米尼克？告诉我们那是谁，让我们惊讶一下。那是拉莫特的爱人之一。是的，你让我震惊。他走开了，把它给了拉莫特的丈夫。所以那非常非常萨德侯爵。是的。所以丈夫然后把它拆开，开始试图在巴黎各地销赃钻石，但在巴黎这样做显然很危险，
want desperately to believe that what they're being told is the case. Yeah, of course. And just to be clear what the confidence trick is, because it's quite complicated. And so therefore the story is quite complicated as well. Essentially Lamotte wants to get hold of this enormous diamond necklace. She wants to have it delivered up to her and to do that she's embroiling the Cardinal in an incredibly complicated scam and whether Calliostro is part of it or not I mean there's part that certainty is impossible on that. But Lamotte's wheeze for getting the Cardinal de Rohan to believe that Marie Antoinette wants it. I mean, this is what this entire scam in the garden is about. So it's Lamotte. She's the one who is getting Nicole to come out, telling her to go
所以他然后去了伦敦，开始在那里做。与此同时，当然，珠宝商在等他们的钱，红衣主教在等他被承诺的王后青睐的迹象。他去宫廷，他有点在等着用这条可爱的项链见王后，带着项链，绝对什么都没有。所以7月初，他想，你知道，我得看看发生了什么。所以他给玛丽·安托瓦内特写了一张谨慎的便条，有点说，非常期待见到这些。
out into the garden and to meet Marie Antoinette. Of course, she's not meeting Marie Antoinette. The whole thing is a scam. And the reason that Nicole has been chosen is because she looks like Marie Antoinette. And so therefore, we'll convince the Cardinal de Roja that this is all above board. And it all goes tremendously well. Nicole has played her part. Lamotte has her dump back in Paris. That's why no further contact is made with her. And it works brilliantly because now the Cardinal is convinced that Marie Antoinette genuinely wants this diamond necklace.
眨眼，眨眼。你知道我为你准备了什么，嗯？嗯？捅捅，捅捅。哦，天哪。玛丽·安托瓦内特认为他疯了，直接处理掉了这封信。是的，当然。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And of course, it's not just the cardinal who is being suckered, it's the jewellers as well. The jewellers too want to believe that the queen wants this necklace because otherwise, you know, they're ruined unless they can offload it. Yeah. So November 1784, so this is, you know, a few months after the meeting in the gardens at Versailles, the cardinal gets a letter that has been signed, Marie Antoinette de France, which is a signature she would never use because that's not diplomatic at all. And the cardinal as a former diplomat should have known this, but he doesn't. And in this letter, he gets informed that the cardinal is to acquire the necklace for the queen
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。然后8月初，珠宝商因为现在面临破产而非常绝望，他们去找了玛丽·安托瓦内特的一位侍女，说，看，王后承诺给我们的钱在哪里？他们去找了王后。
and that the queen will pay for it in four installments. So brilliant. The jewelers are delighted. The cardinal is delighted. You know, this is his way back. So on the 29th of January, 1785, the jewelers give the cardinal the necklace. A courier then arrives who claims to be from the queen. The cardinal gives the necklace to this courier. What a fool that cardinal is, Tom. I mean, unbelievable. Do you think it's the courier, Dominic? is it tell us who it is surprise us it's one of lamotte's lovers yeah you astound me and he goes away he gives it to lamotte's husband so that's very very marquis de sade yeah so the husband then breaks it up and he starts trying to fence the diamonds around paris but it's obviously dangerous to be doing it in paris
而且王后将分四期付款。太棒了。珠宝商们很高兴。红衣主教也很高兴。你知道，这是他东山再起的机会。所以1785年1月29日，珠宝商们把项链交给了红衣主教。随后，一名自称来自王后的信使抵达。红衣主教把项链交给了这名信使。汤姆，那个红衣主教真是个傻瓜。我是说，简直不可思议。多米尼克，你觉得那是信使吗？告诉我们那是谁，给我们个惊喜吧。那是拉莫特的情人之一。是啊，你真是让我大吃一惊。他带着项链走了，把它交给了拉莫特的丈夫，这真是太萨德侯爵风格了。是的，于是她的丈夫把项链拆开，开始试图在巴黎销赃这些钻石，但在巴黎做这种事显然很危险。
so he then goes to lond London and starts doing it there. Meanwhile, of course, the jewellers are waiting for their money and the cardinal is waiting for signs of the Queen's favour that he's been promised. And he goes to court and he's kind of waiting to see the Queen with this lovely necklace, with the necklace, absolutely nothing. So early July, he thinks, you know, I've got to see what's going on. So he sends Marie Antoinette a discreet note, kind of saying, very much looking forward to seeing these.
所以他后来去了伦敦，开始在那里销赃。与此同时，珠宝商们当然在等着收钱，而红衣主教则在等待他被承诺的王后恩宠的迹象。他去了宫廷，本想带着这条漂亮的项链去见王后，结果什么也没发生。所以七月初，他想，我得弄清楚发生了什么。于是他给玛丽·安托瓦内特写了一张谨慎的字条，大意是说，非常期待看到这些东西。
Wink, wink. You know what I've got you, eh? Eh? Nudge, nudge. Oh, God. And Marie Antoinette thinks he's mad and just disposes of the letter. Yeah, of course. I'm Marina Hyde.
挤眉弄眼。你知道我给你准备了什么，对吧？嗯？暗示一下。天哪。玛丽·安托瓦内特觉得他疯了，直接把信扔了。是的，当然。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. And then early in August, the jewellers are so desperate because they're now facing bankruptcy that they go to one of Marie Antoinette's ladies-in-waiting and say, look, where's this money that the Queen promised us? And they go to the Queen.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕后，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。然后八月初，珠宝商们因为面临破产而走投无路，他们去找了玛丽·安托瓦内特的一位侍女，说，看，王后承诺给我们的钱在哪里？于是她们去找了王后。
She's got no idea that any of this has been going on. And Marie Antoinette leads the investigation. Personally, understandably, she's appalled. I mean, she's completely innocent. And yet her good name has been consistently abused throughout the entire affair. And she has this kind of dramatic declaration of purpose. Hideous vices must be unmasked. The purple of a cardinal and the title of a prince have cloaked a money grabber, a fraudster who dares to compromise the wife of his sovereign. France and all of Europe shall know of it. And so she goes to the king and the king issues orders
她根本不知道这一切正在发生。玛丽·安托瓦内特亲自领导了调查。可以理解，她感到非常震惊。我的意思是，她是完全无辜的。然而，在整个事件中，她的名誉却一直受到诋毁。她发表了一番戏剧性的宣言：必须揭露那些丑陋的罪恶。红衣主教的紫色长袍和王子的头衔掩盖了一个贪财鬼、一个竟敢玷污君主妻子的骗子。法国和整个欧洲都将知道这一切。于是她去找国王，国王下达了命令
that the cardinal be arrested. And so he is on the 15th of August and he is arrested while he's holding mass to celebrate the ascension of the Virgin in the chapel at Versailles. He's in his full robes, you know, smoke, bells, the works. In come the king's guards he's arrested and taken off to the bastille crikey tom what a story this is so listen everybody come back after the break to find out what happens next welcome back to the rest is history napoleon Bonaparte in later life said that the death of Marie Antoinette began at the trial of the diamond necklace conspirators. And Tom, that's a big claim.
逮捕红衣主教。8月15日，当他在凡尔赛宫的小教堂主持弥撒，庆祝圣母升天时，他被捕了。他当时身穿全套法衣，你知道的，烟雾缭绕，钟声齐鸣，排场十足。国王的卫兵冲进来将他逮捕，并带往巴士底狱。天哪，汤姆，这真是个精彩的故事。好了，各位，休息之后回来，看看接下来会发生什么。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。拿破仑·波拿巴晚年曾说，玛丽·安托瓦内特的死亡始于钻石项链阴谋案的审判。汤姆，这可是个惊人的说法。
Who am I to argue in Napoleon? Yeah, he was there. Now, why would one say that of something that on the surface seems a little bit inconsequential? And of course, in which the queen is not really involved right i mean i guess if people said well of course the french revolution a scandal about a necklace would be low down the list very low down the list yeah you've got bread riots fiscal incompetence all kinds of things which we will be looking at in due course but i think that the answer to why
我有什么资格反驳拿破仑呢？是的，他当时就在现场。那么，为什么会有人对一件表面上看起来微不足道的事情这样评价呢？当然，王后并没有真正参与其中，对吧？我想如果人们说，当然，法国大革命，关于项链的丑闻在名单上会排得很靠后，非常靠后。是的，还有面包暴动、财政无能等等各种各样的事情，我们以后会一一探讨。但我认为，为什么
it is so damaging to the queen is the way that the scandal comes to be teased out and the way that it goes public. So what happens is that all the main participants in the scandal, so the Cardinal, Nicole, aka the Baron d'Oliva, the Comte de Cagliostro, and of course de Lamotte, they're all arrested and they're all brought to trial. And trials that they have are open so you know the proceedings can be reported and so you know the queen had said all of france and europe shall hear of this this is exactly what happens but it doesn't work to her advantage well just on that so the openness i think it's important that people get a sense of just what an enormous appetite for news and gossip there is in Paris in particular
这对王后如此具有破坏性的原因，在于这起丑闻被揭露的方式以及它公之于众的过程。事情是这样的，丑闻的所有主要参与者，也就是红衣主教、妮可（又名奥利瓦男爵夫人）、卡里奥斯特罗伯爵，当然还有德·拉莫特夫人，他们都被逮捕并接受了审判。这些审判是公开的，所以你知道诉讼程序可以被报道，所以你知道王后曾说“全法国和欧洲都将听到这件事”，这正是发生的事情，但这并没有对她有利。嗯，就这一点而言，我认为人们了解巴黎当时对新闻和八卦的巨大胃口是很重要的，特别是在
in the 1780s. So we mentioned earlier Robert Darnton's brilliant book, The Revolutionary Temper. And he talks in that about how all the different lawyers, we mentioned this didn't mean the first half Tom, that the different lawyers of the various participants publish these, what they call these memoirs of the case while the case is going on. And these would go through multiple editions and they would sell tens of thousands of copies and people would literally read them out in cafes and people would gather to read them together. It's a kind of collective experience of the news and of rumour and gossip. And this case is the perfect story for all that. And it actually ties together all these anxieties and sort of fantasies about Mariternet that have been gathering pace for more than a decade.
18世纪80年代。我们之前提到了罗伯特·达恩顿那本出色的书《革命的脾气》。他在书中谈到了不同的律师，我们之前提到过，这并不是指汤姆的前半部分，即各方参与者的不同律师在案件审理期间出版了他们所谓的“案件回忆录”。这些书会多次再版，销量达数万册，人们真的会在咖啡馆里朗读它们，大家聚在一起阅读。这是一种关于新闻、谣言和八卦的集体体验。而这个案件是所有这些的完美素材。它实际上将十多年来一直不断发酵的关于玛丽·安托瓦内特的各种焦虑和幻想联系在了一起。
The closest parallel I can think of from modern times would be the way in which the failure of the marriage of Prince Charles and Diana kind of exploded. There was gossip about it. There were whisperings about it. There was talk about it. And then suddenly it was all brought out into the open and there was this absolute kind of firestorm of obsession. And I think that that is basically what happens. And it's devastating for Marie Antoinette and for the crown generally, because all the protagonists in various ways come to be exonerated. Three of them are legally exonerated. Four of them are kind of basically exonerated before the bar of public opinion. And so the crown is left completely baffled and perplexed
我能想到的现代最接近的例子是查尔斯王子和戴安娜王妃的婚姻破裂爆发的方式。当时有关于它的八卦，有关于它的窃窃私语，有关于它的议论。然后突然间，一切都被公之于众，引发了一场绝对的痴迷风暴。我认为这基本上就是所发生的事情。这对玛丽·安托瓦内特和整个王室来说都是毁灭性的，因为所有的主角在某种程度上都得到了开脱。其中三人从法律上被开脱。四人在公众舆论面前基本上被开脱了。所以王室感到完全困惑和不知所措，
and wounded by this. So to go through the various participants in these trials, three of them, all of whom have been sent to the Bastille. And to be sent to the Bastille in this period, to go to the Bastille, the Bastille is the symbol of royal oppression. So it kind of immediately makes them heroes. People are instinctively on their side. Yeah. So the cardinal, when he goes to the Bastille, he is improbably cast as a kind of victim of royal oppression. He becomes the people's cardinal. But the thing is, Simon Sharma says in Citizens, he actually moved into a specially furnished apartment outside the prison
并因此受到伤害。那么，回顾这些审判中的各方参与者，其中三人，他们都被送进了巴士底狱。在那个时期被送进巴士底狱，去巴士底狱，巴士底狱是王室压迫的象征。所以这立刻使他们成为了英雄。人们本能地站在他们这一边。是的。所以红衣主教，当他进入巴士底狱时，他不可思议地被塑造成了王室压迫的受害者。他成了“人民的红衣主教”。但问题是，西蒙·沙玛在《公民》一书中说，他实际上搬进了一间位于监狱外、经过特别布置的公寓，
where he spent nine months entertaining a stream of distinguished visitors. Oysters and champagne were laid on as a collation for guests. And the cardinal was allowed choice works from his library and a retinue of servants to help him overcome the hardships of incarceration. But the image is that they're dripping water and clanking chains and rats and straw and everything. But it's not at all like that. And he says that he doesn't want the king to try it, basically because he doesn't trust the king. And so he says he wants to go to the Parlement de Paris. And the Parlement is not a parliament. It's kind of like the high court. So he goes on court there. It's open. And his lawyer presents him as a kind of Rousseau-esque
在那里他花了九个月的时间招待了一连串尊贵的访客。牡蛎和香槟被作为客人的点心。红衣主教被允许从他的图书馆里挑选书籍，还有一群仆人帮助他克服监禁的艰辛。但人们的印象是那里滴着水、锁链叮当响、有老鼠和稻草等等。但事实完全不是那样。他说他不想让国王审判他，基本上是因为他不信任国王。所以他说他想去巴黎高等法院。而高等法院并不是议会。它有点像最高法院。所以他在那里受审。它是公开的。他的律师把他塑造成一个卢梭式的
figure, a figure who has an excess of candour. He's at one with nature. He's not suited to the machinations of a corrupt and decadent court. He's mother nature's child, all that kind of thing. And also, he just wanted to serve the queen. It was his chivalrous duty. He's been made a fool of in this story, but he's not a conspirator. I mean, he's not a criminal. No. So there is a measure of truth there. They were right to acquit him. Yeah. And so he does get acquitted. But the implications of this are devastating for Marie Antoinette, and Jonathan Beckman spells it out. Louis and Marie Antoinette could scarcely believe that the Parlement had, in effect, ruled that the Queen could be mistaken for the kind of woman who might arrange a midnight assignation by a ruinously expensive necklace without her husband's permission and correspond in secret with a known roué.
人物，一个拥有过剩坦率的人。他与自然融为一体。他不适合腐败和颓废宫廷的阴谋。他是大自然的孩子，诸如此类。而且，他只是想为王后服务。这是他的骑士职责。他在这个故事中被愚弄了，但他不是阴谋家。我的意思是，他不是罪犯。不。所以这里有一定的真实性。他们判他无罪是正确的。是的。所以他确实被判无罪了。但这对玛丽·安托瓦内特的影响是毁灭性的，乔纳森·贝克曼阐述了这一点。路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特几乎不敢相信，高等法院实际上裁定，王后可能会被误认为是那种在没有丈夫允许的情况下，为了昂贵的项链而安排午夜幽会，并与一个众所周知的浪子秘密通信的女人。
Right, because if you're assuming that he could be easily fooled, then you're assuming that the possibility exists that she could have behaved like this. You and I know, and everybody who's read the books on her knows that she would never have behaved like this, but the French public have been primed to think that she might. Yeah, absolutely. And he retires to Strasbourg where he's greeted as a kind of, you know, an oppressed innocent. So that's him. Nicole, the Baron d'Oliva, the account that we gave, as we said, that's basically derives from the lawyer that she has, who essentially casts her as the kind of heroine of a novel. And if it sounded like a novel, then I think, you know, there may be kind of element of that. But I think the basic outline of what happened is true, but clearly it's been kind of slightly enhanced. I mean,
没错，因为如果你假设他很容易被愚弄，那么你就假设存在她可能做出这种行为的可能性。你和我都知道，所有读过关于她的书的人都知道，她绝不会做出这种行为，但法国公众已经被引导去认为她可能会。是的，绝对是这样。他退休去了斯特拉斯堡，在那里他被当作一个“受压迫的无辜者”受到欢迎。所以这就是他。妮可，奥利瓦男爵夫人，我们给出的描述，正如我们所说，基本上源于她的律师，他本质上把她塑造成了小说中的女主角。如果听起来像小说，那么我想，你知道，可能确实有那样的成分。但我认为所发生事情的基本轮廓是真实的，但显然它被稍微润色了。我的意思是，
she is a victim of it, really. She's been made a tool. She's been made a dupe of. Yes. And what makes people even more sympathetic is that in the Bastille, she's given birth to a baby, you know, so that makes her even more of a kind of sentimental heroine of a Rousseau novel. So the Comte de Cagliostro. He's a great character. In the Bastille, he continues to play the part of the Magus, the man who is 3,000 years old. There's brilliant detail in his interrogation in the Bastille. He's asked, do you have any regrets about the life that you've led? Calimastro replies, yeah, I feel terrible about the assassination of Pompey the Great and my role in that. Pompey the Great, the great rival of Julius Caesar, had been killed 2,000 years before.
她确实是受害者。她被当作了工具。她被当作了傻瓜。是的。让人们更加同情的是，在巴士底狱，她生下了一个婴儿，你知道，所以这使她更像是一个卢梭小说中感伤的女主角。至于卡里奥斯特罗伯爵。他是个了不起的角色。在巴士底狱，他继续扮演着“法师”的角色，那个活了3000岁的人。他在巴士底狱的审讯细节非常精彩。他被问到，你对你所过的生活有什么遗憾吗？卡里奥斯特罗回答说，是的，我对庞培大帝的遇刺以及我在其中的角色感到非常难过。庞培大帝，尤利乌斯·凯撒的伟大对手，在2000年前就被杀了。
So that's brilliant. But once he gets to his trial, he immediately switches around and suddenly casts himself as a kind of cool enlightenment sceptic. And he gets asked by the prosecution lawyer, why do you say that you're thousands of years old? And he says, I'm not. I'm 37. Yeah. So lots of the stories about Calliope, to be fair, come from pamphlets about him rather than things himself. So the Pompey, the great story, I mean, he probably either said it as a joke or didn't say it. Anyway, he's a good character. I like him.
所以这太精彩了。但一旦他进入审判，他立刻转变了态度，突然把自己塑造成一个冷静的启蒙运动怀疑论者。检察官问他，你为什么说你活了几千年？他说，我没有。我37岁。是的。所以关于卡里奥斯特罗的很多故事，公平地说，来自关于他的小册子，而不是他自己说的话。所以庞培大帝的故事，我的意思是，他可能要么是开玩笑说的，要么根本没说。无论如何，他是个好角色。我喜欢他。
And actually, the government account, which was by Barrister Gautagier, he wrote a memoir and it was the sort of government approved one. Basically, he said Cagliostro had nothing to do with this at all. He was dragged in as window dressing. But he was apparently in Lyon when the whole thing was taking place anyway. Difficult to know because he's such a fraud. No, that's true. I don't think you could trust anything that he says. So it's difficult to know, but I mean, he gets off. People agree that he doesn't have anything to do with it. As for Jeanne de Lamotte, the confidence trickster, she is convicted. The evidence against her is overwhelming. I mean, she's basically banged her rights. But amazingly, even she wins public sympathy.
事实上，由律师戈塔吉耶撰写的政府报告，他写了一份回忆录，那是政府批准的版本。基本上，他说卡里奥斯特罗与此事完全无关。他被拉进来只是为了充门面。但无论如何，当整件事发生时，他显然在里昂。很难知道，因为他是个彻头彻尾的骗子。不，那是真的。我不认为你能相信他说的任何话。所以很难知道，但我的意思是，他脱身了。人们同意他与此事无关。至于珍妮·德·拉莫特，那个诈骗犯，她被定罪了。针对她的证据是压倒性的。我的意思是，她基本上是罪有应得。但令人惊讶的是，即使是她也赢得了公众的同情。
Essentially, her defense is that everything that she said was true, that Marie Antoinette was guilty, that she had wanted the necklace, that she had written loads of letters, that she was in Versailles. So she gets sentenced to life imprisonment in the Sol Petrière. It's a kind of former munitions factory, isn't it? That is notorious as the place where prostitutes get sent. It's basically a prostitute's prison. Yeah. So she gets taken there and she hasn't been told before the sentence is read to her what she's going to suffer. So she's taken to the prison. It's read out to her. She's told that
本质上，她的辩护是她所说的一切都是真的，玛丽·安托瓦内特是有罪的，她想要那条项链，她写了大量的信，她在凡尔赛。所以她被判处在萨尔佩特里埃监狱终身监禁。那是一个前军火工厂，不是吗？它以关押妓女的地方而闻名。它基本上是一个妓女监狱。是的。所以她被带到那里，在判决宣读给她听之前，她并不知道自己将遭受什么。所以她被带到监狱。判决宣读给她听。她被告知
she's going to be birched, branded and be imprisoned for life. And she goes absolutely ballistic. She starts kind of scratching and writhing. She bites a chunk out of the executioner. She kind of swallows his flesh, so it is said. And she's pinned down and the branding iron has V on it for voleurs, for thief. One of the brands is successfully imprinted, but the other one, she's twisting so much that it burns her breast and this kind of stench of roasting meat. So very, very horrible. And she's then taken inside. She's given a kind of pudding bowl. So all her hair is chopped off and then she is put into a rough grey Hessian dress and locked up. And amazingly in 1787, so only a couple of years later, she escapes. And immediately it's assumed that this is all part of conspiracy, that the Queen wants her out of the way. And there may be an element of the fact, I mean,
她将被鞭笞、烙印并终身监禁。她彻底崩溃了。她开始抓挠和扭动。她从刽子手身上咬下一块肉。据说她吞下了他的肉。她被按住，烙铁上有一个“V”字，代表“小偷”（voleurs）。其中一个烙印成功印上了，但另一个，她扭动得太厉害，以至于烧伤了她的胸部，散发出一种烤肉的恶臭。所以非常非常可怕。然后她被带进去。她被给了一个像布丁碗一样的发型，所以她所有的头发都被剪掉了，然后她被穿上一件粗糙的灰色麻布裙子并被锁了起来。令人惊讶的是，在1787年，也就是仅仅几年后，她逃跑了。人们立刻认为这都是阴谋的一部分，王后想除掉她。可能确实有这样的因素，我的意思是，
I don't know, maybe it's possible, who knows. Anyway, she gets to London and when she's there, she writes this venomously slanderous attack on the Queen. She claims to have had a sapphic relationship with Marie Antoinette. She describes midnight assignations with the Queen. Heavens, I found her so beautiful. I said to myself, it is the goddess Flora toying with a humble little flower. So the idea of Marie Antoinette as predatory, as domineering. Yeah, has groomed her. Has groomed her. Yes, exactly. And Chantal Thomas says of her, she was the Justine of the pre-revolutionary epic. And Justine is the heroine of the Marquis de Sade's most famous novel. And Justine is impeccably virtuous. And because she is virtuous, she is persecuted by the kind of Sardian monsters,
我不知道，也许有可能，谁知道呢。无论如何，她到了伦敦，在那里，她写了一篇对王后恶毒诽谤的攻击文章。她声称与玛丽·安托瓦内特有过萨福式的关系。她描述了与王后的午夜幽会。天哪，我发现她如此美丽。我对自己说，这是女神弗洛拉在戏弄一朵卑微的小花。所以玛丽·安托瓦内特被描绘成掠夺性的、专横的。是的，已经驯化了她。已经驯化了她。是的，完全正确。尚塔尔·托马斯这样评价她：她是前革命时代的“朱斯蒂娜”。而朱斯蒂娜是萨德侯爵最著名小说中的女主角。朱斯蒂娜是无可挑剔的贞洁。正因为她贞洁，她才受到萨德式怪物的迫害，
the aristocrats. And essentially, if she is the Justine, then Marie Antoinette is a kind of Sardian monster. corrupted personally by Marie Antoinette. And of course, that may seem completely bonkers because we know, as you discussed so brilliantly in the last episode, Tom, that Marie Antoinette is actually quite, she's not puritanical, but she's very bourgeois. Her sexual morality is bourgeois, Tom. She's a combination. I mean, she's Catholic and she's Rousseauian. She's a combination of kind of old school Catholic morality combined with a kind of girlish giddiness. Fair enough. But what she isn't, she is not a predatory lesbian sort of groomer of little girls or young women or whatever this woman is claiming. But the problem is that these are
那些贵族。本质上，如果她是朱斯蒂娜，那么玛丽·安托瓦内特就是一种萨德式的怪物。被玛丽·安托瓦内特个人腐蚀了。当然，这看起来可能完全疯狂，因为我们知道，正如你在上一集中如此精彩地讨论的那样，汤姆，玛丽·安托瓦内特实际上相当……她不是清教徒，但她非常资产阶级。她的性道德是资产阶级的，汤姆。她是两者的结合。我的意思是，她是天主教徒，也是卢梭主义者。她是老派天主教道德与一种少女般轻浮的结合。好吧。但她不是，她不是一个掠夺性的女同性恋，也不是什么小女孩或年轻女性的驯化者，或者这个女人声称的任何东西。但问题是，这些是
portrayals of her that have already gained traction, that she's a monster of extravagance and that she's a kind of predatory whore. And the reason this scandal is so devastating is both that it amplifies those stories and that it makes them kind of very, very public. And so in the wake of it, the portrayal of her as a kind of monstrous nymphomaniac is completely turbocharged. So by 1789, and we all know what happens in 1789, a pamphlet is published, which describes her sexual record. Nobility, clergy, third estate. This is the backdrop to the meeting of the three estates, which we'll be doing in due course. So it's obviously inspired by it. Any man has a right to her favours. The most handsome and robust are
已经获得关注的对她的描绘，说她是一个挥霍无度的怪物，是一个掠夺性的妓女。这起丑闻之所以如此具有破坏性，是因为它既放大了这些故事，又使它们变得非常非常公开。因此，在丑闻之后，她作为一种怪物般的色情狂的形象被彻底“涡轮增压”了。所以到了1789年，我们都知道1789年发生了什么，一本小册子出版了，描述了她的性记录。贵族、教士、第三等级。这是三级会议召开的背景，我们稍后会讨论。所以这显然是受此启发。任何男人都有权享受她的恩宠。最英俊、最强壮的是
the most welcome guards, lackeys, actors, height actors height of appropriate oh indelible shame yeah so kind of loving it and it's not just the queen who gets caught up on this so also does her female favorites so this is when the stories about the duchess de polignac who we talked about yesterday one of her squad they get vituperative as well duchess de Polignac is relatively harmless, so is the Princesse de Lombard. But they are both cast as kind of co-vampires in Marie Antoinette's nymphomaniac coven. Queens of vice, Tom. Queens of vice. And what's fascinating is that in the wake of the punishment of Delamotte, you start to get fantasies in which Marie Antoinette and her favourites suffer similar punishments. So a lampoon is published against the Duchess de Polignac, and it kind of says, let's see her humiliated. Let's see her punished. Let's see her suffer before the gaze of the
最受欢迎的卫兵、仆人、演员、演员……这是何等的……哦，不可磨灭的耻辱。是的，所以人们很喜欢它。而且不仅仅是王后被卷入其中，她的女性宠臣也一样。这就是关于波利尼亚克公爵夫人的故事，我们昨天谈到过，她的小圈子，她们也受到了恶毒的攻击。波利尼亚克公爵夫人相对无害，朗巴尔亲王夫人也是。但她们都被塑造成玛丽·安托瓦内特色情狂女巫团中的“吸血鬼同伙”。罪恶女王，汤姆。罪恶女王。令人着迷的是，在德·拉莫特受到惩罚后，你开始看到一些幻想，其中玛丽·安托瓦内特和她的宠臣们遭受了类似的惩罚。所以一本针对波利尼亚克公爵夫人的讽刺文出版了，它说，让我们看看她受辱。让我们看看她受罚。让我们看看她在
people. Yes, Madame, you must do penance. And as the choice is up to the confessor, here is the penance I impose in the name of the nation. Shave your head, don a grey Hessian dress as your only adornment, and go to the august assembly of the estates general in this garb to make atonement and deliver up any remains of your plundering so it's kind of working with yeah you know the punishments of convicted prostitutes and also the austrian this is really important here isn't it because there are two claims additional to this one that's very common is that um she actually her first victim as it were or the first person who perhaps groomed her was her own brother the austrian emperor joseph ii yeah so the mozart thing he's the too many notes king in amadeus yeah yes he is yeah but then the other thing is of
人民的注视下受苦。是的，夫人，你必须忏悔。既然选择权在忏悔神父手中，这就是我以国家的名义强加给你的忏悔。剃光你的头，穿上一件灰色麻布裙子作为你唯一的装饰，并以这种装束去参加庄严的三级会议，以赎罪并交出你掠夺的任何残余。所以这有点像……是的，你知道，对被定罪的妓女的惩罚，还有奥地利人……这一点在这里非常重要，不是吗？因为除了这个之外还有两个主张，一个非常普遍的说法是，嗯，她实际上……她的第一个受害者，或者说第一个可能驯化她的人，是她自己的兄弟，奥地利皇帝约瑟夫二世。是的，莫扎特那件事，他在《莫扎特传》里是那个“音符太多”的国王。是的，他确实是。但另一件事是，
course that if she is austrian she's not french and she must therefore be a traitor yeah and the more that the international temperature kind of rises, especially once the revolution has got going, the more people say, you know, she is not merely sexually kind of depraved, she's politically depraved. And, you know, in the course of her sapphic lusts, she is absorbing secrets and passing on secrets to France's enemies. Exactly so. And there's a sense that Maria Theresa, her mother, has sent her to infect France with her villainy. So you may wonder, well, how on earth does Marie Antoinette cope
当然，如果她是奥地利人，她就不是法国人，因此她一定是个叛徒。是的，国际局势越紧张，特别是一旦革命开始，人们就越说，你知道，她不仅在性方面堕落，她在政治上也堕落。而且，你知道，在她的萨福式欲望中，她正在吸收秘密并把秘密传递给法国的敌人。完全正确。而且有一种感觉，玛丽·特蕾莎，她的母亲，派她来用她的邪恶感染法国。所以你可能想知道，玛丽·安托瓦内特到底是如何应对
with all this abuse? And the truth is that she treats it all with kind of amused disdain. So as early as 1775, she wrote to Maria Theresa, Maria Teresa her mother saying we're in the middle of a satirical song epidemic they have made some up about everyone at court men and women alike French license is even extended to the king
所有这些辱骂的？事实是，她以一种戏谑的蔑视态度对待这一切。早在1775年，她就写信给玛丽·特蕾莎，她的母亲，说我们正处于讽刺歌曲的流行之中，他们为宫廷里的每个人都编了一些，男人和女人一样。法国的放纵甚至延伸到了国王身上。
I myself have not been spared although this country is fond enough of malice the songs are so flat and in such bad taste that they are successful neither with the public
我本人也没有幸免，尽管这个国家足够喜欢恶意，但这些歌曲太平淡，品味太差，以至于它们在公众中既不成功，
nor high society so two things there one she's only 20 years old when she says that so I always find the stuff about Marianne Trenet unbelievably repulsive. It's awful.
也不在高级社交圈中成功。所以这里有两点，第一，她说这话时才20岁。所以我总是觉得关于玛丽·安托瓦内特的那些东西令人难以置信地令人作呕。太可怕了。
I mean, I just think how anybody can take the side of the pamphleteers and not of the basically girl stroke young woman at the centre of them is beyond me. But the other interesting thing is that she is quite wrong about that. So when she says successful neither with the public nor high society. She is dead wrong. They are enormously successful and people do start to believe it. Yeah. And so Chantal Thomas in her wonderful book about the pamphlets and Marie Antoinette's relationship to them, I mean, she basically says that one of the reasons perhaps why they don't impinge on Marie Antoinette is that she simply doesn't understand the power of the written word. Because she doesn't read. She doesn't really read. And she says, Marie Antoinette had nothing to learn from the outside world. The hot-headed, vehement words of the pamphlets were incomprehensible to her and so failed to touch her. But, you know, there are expressions of public hostility that do have an impact. So in May 1785, and this is, you know, when the scandal is
我的意思是，我只是觉得怎么会有人站在小册子作者一边，而不是站在处于中心位置的那个女孩/年轻女性一边，这让我无法理解。但另一件有趣的事情是，她对此完全错了。所以当她说“在公众和高级社交圈中都不成功”时。她大错特错了。它们非常成功，人们确实开始相信了。是的。所以尚塔尔·托马斯在她那本关于小册子和玛丽·安托瓦内特与它们关系的精彩著作中，我的意思是，她基本上说，也许它们没有影响到玛丽·安托瓦内特的原因之一是，她根本不理解文字的力量。因为她不读书。她真的不读书。她说，玛丽·安托瓦内特从外部世界学不到任何东西。小册子中头脑发热、激烈的言辞对她来说是不可理解的，因此未能触动她。但是，你知道，确实有一些公众敌意的表达产生了影响。所以1785年5月，这是，你知道，当丑闻
kind of really building up, she goes into Paris and the people there refuse to cheer her. And two years later, she's being booed and hissed on the streets of Paris. Well, Tom, you say that, but actually Theo, our producer, would tell you that people aren't booing and hissing. They are shouting out, ooh, ooh, and gee, gee, gee. That's their equivalent of hissing. Yeah, that's French for boo. Exactly. Yeah. So, you know, one of the chiefs of police in Paris writes to the king at Versailles and says that the queen shouldn't go into the capital. It's unsafe for her. And so Louis XVI passes this on to his wife and forbids her to go to Paris. And Marie Antoinette is deeply, deeply wounded by this. And so she cancels her public engagements in the capital. And she basically retreats to the Petit Trianon, which of course
真正建立起来的时候，她进入巴黎，那里的人们拒绝为她欢呼。两年后，她在巴黎街头被嘘声和嘶嘶声淹没。嗯，汤姆，你这么说，但实际上西奥，我们的制片人，会告诉你人们并没有在嘘和嘶。他们是在大喊“呜，呜”和“叽，叽，叽”。那是他们相当于嘶嘶声的表达。是的，那是法语里的嘘声。完全正确。是的。所以，你知道，巴黎的一位警察局长写信给凡尔赛的国王，说王后不应该去首都。这对她来说不安全。于是路易十六把这个转达给了他的妻子，并禁止她去巴黎。玛丽·安托瓦内特对此深感受伤。于是她取消了她在首都的公开活动。她基本上退居到了小特里亚农宫，这当然
then only makes the stories, what's she up to in there with all her, you know, her girlfriends. Exactly. That's the tragedy of it, right? The irony is, of course, she cannot win. She's in a position now where whatever she does will be seen as evidence of guilt. So ironically, the fact that she tried to be less formal than the court is seen as, you know, she's not a good queen. The fact that she's got her group of friends, she's a lesbian. The fact that she's not going into the city because she's being booed, that shows she's arrogant
然后只会让那些故事……她在那里和她所有的，你知道，女朋友们在做什么？完全正确。这就是它的悲剧，对吧？讽刺的是，当然，她赢不了。她现在处于一种无论她做什么都会被视为有罪证据的境地。所以讽刺的是，她试图比宫廷更不拘礼节的事实被视为，你知道，她不是一个好王后。她有她的朋友群的事实，她是女同性恋。她没有进城因为她被嘘的事实，这表明她傲慢
and she doesn't care about the people and a traitor. She cannot win. I feel really sorry for her. And so you may wonder, well, does this matter? Does any of this matter? It's just surface froth.
而且她不关心人民，是个叛徒。她赢不了。我真的很同情她。所以你可能想知道，这重要吗？这一切重要吗？这只是表面的泡沫。
It does matter because it doesn't just damage the queen. The whole scandal of the diamond necklace has also seriously, for the first time, damaged the public reputation of the king. You know, again, there have been kind of rumors bubbling under the surface. But again, it is this trial that brings slanders against the king to the surface. And there are two things that they focus. The first is that he is cast as a despot.
这确实重要，因为它不仅损害了王后。整个钻石项链丑闻也第一次严重损害了国王的公众声誉。你知道，同样，表面下一直有谣言在冒泡。但同样，正是这次审判将针对国王的诽谤带到了表面。他们关注两件事。第一是，他被塑造成一个暴君。
You know, he is the man who has sent all these people to the Bastille. He's a monster. He's an autocrat who doesn't respect the liberty of the people. And as we'll see next time, that has enormous traction because of the political and financial crisis that France finds itself in. It does, absolutely. And the tragedy is, in a way, the king has kind of absorbed some of the lessons. So his treatment of Beaumarchais, who has written a preface to one of his plays that the king interprets as being an attack on him, he orders Beaumarchais to be arrested. But this time he doesn't send him to the Bastille. He sends him to a prison called the Saint-Lazare, which is a correction centre for delinquent
你知道，他是那个把所有这些人送进巴士底狱的人。他是个怪物。他是一个不尊重人民自由的独裁者。正如我们下次将看到的，由于法国所处的政治和金融危机，这具有巨大的影响力。确实，绝对是这样。悲剧在于，在某种程度上，国王已经吸收了一些教训。所以他对博马舍的处理，博马舍为他的一部戏剧写了一篇序言，国王将其解释为对他的攻击，他下令逮捕博马舍。但这次他没有把他送进巴士底狱。他把他送进了一个叫圣拉扎尔的监狱，那是一个针对犯罪
boys, you know, where they're taught the error of their ways and kind of given the birch and things like that. And everyone finds this hilarious. And so Beaumarchais, who'd always had laughter on his side, now finds that the laughter is against him. And basically his reputation is destroyed by it. So it suggests the king is kind of learning how to play the game. The king, by the way, it's not a despot. I mean, that's one thing that's really worth stressing. There are many things that Louis XVI gets wrong, but being too bloodthirsty, too repressive is definitely, I don't think there's any historian who would think that was one of them. Right. If he'd been a real despot, the Cardinal de Roja would have vanished and wouldn't have
男孩的矫正中心，你知道，在那里他们被教导错误的道路，并受到鞭笞之类的惩罚。每个人都觉得这很滑稽。所以博马舍，他一直有笑声站在他这一边，现在发现笑声是针对他的。基本上他的名誉因此被毁了。所以这表明国王正在学习如何玩这个游戏。顺便说一句，国王并不是一个暴君。我的意思是，这是非常值得强调的一点。路易十六做错了很多事情，但过于嗜血、过于压制绝对是……我不认为有任何历史学家会认为那是其中之一。没错。如果他真的是个暴君，罗昂红衣主教早就消失了，而不会
been sitting in his chambers having kind of capons. But the other thing that this plays into is the idea of the king as sexually inadequate and more specifically now a cookhold. Because if Marie Antoinette is cast as being this kind of voracious nymphomaniac, there is this sense that her powers are being drawn from the sexual inadequacies of the king. And so you get all these rhymes about the size and the- Rigidity or otherwise. The flaccidity of the royal member. Yeah.
坐在他的房间里吃着阉鸡。但这件事还涉及到的另一件事是国王在性方面无能，更具体地说，现在是一个戴绿帽子的丈夫。因为如果玛丽·安托瓦内特被塑造成这种贪婪的色情狂，人们就会有一种感觉，她的力量来自于国王在性方面的无能。所以你得到了所有这些关于尺寸和……的韵文。僵硬与否。皇家成员的松弛。是的。
And in the kind of the account of the queen and the affair that de la Motte writes in London, she says that the cardinal and the queen had been having an affair and that they had been engaged in a conspiracy to make the cardinal the prime minister of France and to subject France to the dominance of Austria. And so the king is somehow seen as being complicit in this. And so the king and queen of France, the emblems of the greatness of the country, are being cast as agents of an enemy power. Robert Danton, in his book, The Revolutionary Temper, quotes a bookseller at the height of the Diamond Necklace Affair, who wrote in his journal,
在德·拉莫特在伦敦写的关于王后和这件事的描述中，她说红衣主教和王后一直在偷情，他们一直在密谋让红衣主教成为法国首相，并使法国屈服于奥地利的统治。所以国王在某种程度上被视为是同谋。因此，法国的国王和王后，这个国家伟大的象征，被塑造成了敌对势力的代理人。罗伯特·达恩顿在他的书《革命的脾气》中，引用了一位在钻石项链事件高潮时的书商的话，他在日记中写道，
or to his brother, I can't remember which, but he wrote, the public spirit has turned against him because he inspires no respect, no fear, no confidence, and he throws away the public's money for all sorts of follies. That is the lesson that if you are a slightly gullible reader of these pamphlets, these propagandistic kind of pornographic fantasies, that's what you think about the king. As D'Arnton says, he's well-meaning but stupid, bewildered, incompetent, timid, indecisive, constantly drunk, unfit even to govern a German principality. Yeah, absolutely. And Danton is brilliant on why this matters, because essentially it's also going with the grain of the crisis that France itself is confronting. That this is a time where the state is running out of money
或者写给他兄弟，我不记得是哪个了，但他写道，公众精神已经转向反对他，因为他没有激发尊重、恐惧或信心，他为了各种愚蠢的事情挥霍公众的钱财。这就是教训，如果你是一个稍微容易受骗的小册子读者，这些宣传性的、色情幻想，这就是你对国王的看法。正如达恩顿所说，他善意但愚蠢、困惑、无能、胆怯、优柔寡断、经常喝醉，甚至不适合治理一个德国小公国。是的，绝对是这样。达恩顿在解释为什么这很重要方面非常出色，因为本质上它也符合法国自身面临的危机。这是一个国家资金耗尽的时代，
and where people are starting to go hungry. There have been a succession of terrible harvests. All this kind of stuff about diamond necklaces and cookholding and cardinals and all kinds of stuff, it does actually matter because it gives colour and venom to what otherwise might be the sense of inchoate forces that are going wrong. And so I think it's important just to emphasise at this point, as we approach the fateful year 1789, that this is not about republicanism. Again, so much of this is coming from within the court. So it's coming from the Duc de Provence, the king's young brother. It's also coming from the Duke of Orléans, the Duc d'Orléans, who is, after the three royal
人们开始挨饿。接连不断的糟糕收成。所有这些关于钻石项链、戴绿帽子、红衣主教和各种各样的事情，确实很重要，因为它给原本可能是不成形的错误力量感增添了色彩和毒性。所以我认为在接近决定性的1789年时，强调这一点很重要，这不是关于共和主义。同样，这其中很多来自宫廷内部。所以它来自普罗旺斯伯爵，国王的弟弟。它也来自奥尔良公爵，他是继三位皇家
brothers, the most significant peer of the realm, who has a whole area of Paris that is his private fiefdom. Yeah, the Palais Royal. The Palais Royal. And so he's basically said anyone can publish what they like there. And so it's become a hotbed of all these kind of pamphlets and stuff. So it absolutely doesn't imply republicanism, but... and publish what they like there. And so it's become a hotbed of all these kind of pamphlets and stuff. So it absolutely doesn't imply republicanism, but... I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
兄弟之后最重要的王国贵族，他在巴黎拥有一整块私人领地。是的，皇家宫殿。皇家宫殿。所以他基本上说任何人都可以在那里出版他们喜欢的任何东西。所以它成了所有这些小册子之类东西的温床。所以它绝对不意味着共和主义，但是……并在那里出版他们喜欢的任何东西。所以它成了所有这些小册子之类东西的温床。所以它绝对不意味着共和主义，但是……我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. It's kind of like the signs of an immunity system going down. And it matters because basically, the whole body politic seems diseased. And Dominic, I think in the next two episodes, we're going to explore beyond the
这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这有点像免疫系统下降的迹象。这很重要，因为基本上，整个政治体似乎都病了。多米尼克，我想在接下来的两集中，我们将探索凡尔赛花园之外，这些疾病是如何在巴黎和乡村表现出来的。所以我们将审视法国在18世纪80年代所处的危机，导致召开三级会议和革命开始的危机。所以会有一些金融，会有很多政治，会有很多饥荒，会有所有这些东西。网球场。当然会有网球场，我们将讨论网球场宣誓，然后当然是巴士底狱的陷落。非常令人兴奋。所以如果你现在想听，而且你记得《历史的余味》俱乐部，你当然可以。如果你不是会员，但你想加入，那么只需前往 therestishistory.com，你就可以注册，
flower gardens of Versailles, exactly how these diseases are kind of manifesting themselves in Paris and in the countryside. So we'll be looking at the crisis that France finds itself in, in the 1780s, the crisis that leads to the calling of the States General and the beginning of the revolution. So there'll be a bit of finance, there'll be a lot of politics, there'll be a lot of famine, there'll be all of this kind of stuff. Tennis courts. There'll be tennis courts, of course, we'll be getting to the tennis court oath, and then of course to the fall of the Bastille. Very exciting. So if you want to listen to that now and you remember the Rest Is History Club, you can, of course. If you're not and you would like to join, then just go to therestishistory.com and you can sign up
你将立即获得本系列的所有剧集，非常令人兴奋。但汤姆，对于那些不打算继续这段旅程的人，我们只能说：再见，周四见，再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
and you'll get all the episodes in this series right away, very excitingly. But Tom, for those people who are not about to continue the journey, all we can say is à bientôt, à jeudi, et au revoir. Au revoir. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你将立即获得本系列的所有剧集，非常令人兴奋。但是汤姆，对于那些不打算继续这段旅程的人，我们只能说：再见，周四见，后会有期。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。